[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to Webisode number
80 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am
very well today.
How are you doing, Fransesc?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: And
most excellent, ever,
I've ever been.
I am very happy we're going to
be continuing the conversation
with Christopher Sansone,
product manager for Container
Builder, but today, we're
going to be talking about kind
of the continuation,
I want to say,
in the topic of CI/CD,
continuous integration
continuous deployment,
about Spinnaker.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: And we
will also have Steven Kim,
and he's software engineering
manager for the Spinnaker team
here at Google.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, super
super love this talk.
It really does, I think, explain
the difference between the CI
and CD, and when you want to
use one and use the other.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and really,
if you don't know what
Spinnaker is at all,
this is going to be
a good introduction.
Because I did not know what
it was until the interview.
So, yeah, lots of
things to learn,
and we're going to start
from, really, the beginning.
So it's going to be fun.
MARK MANDEL: And
after that, we will go
into the question of the week.
We touched on this last
week with the cloud
social repositories going
general availability,
but we want to talk a little
bit about the free tier,
just so people can
understand exactly how they
can take advantage of that, and
how that relates to pricing, as
well.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I think that the wording
was a little bit confusing
on the announcement.
MARK MANDEL: Just
a smidge, yeah.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So we're going
to clarify what it actually
means and what is
free and how much it
costs when you have to pay.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: But
before that, we're
going to go with other
cool things of the week.
And we have a bunch of them.
The first one is
an episode-- it's
an episode-- a blog post, sorry,
ran by our dear coworker, Ahmed
[INAUDIBLE].
He works here at Google,
he's a software engineer
in the Kubernetes
developer relations team.
And he wrote a blog post on
what are the coolest features
of Google Container builder?
So you can either
read that blog post,
or listen to the previous
episode, or do both.
MARK MANDEL: While he
does cover some stuff
we don't talk about in the
previous episode, which
is super cool, and
gives you examples
with like commands of exactly
how you can use Container
Builder to do certain things
like local builds and stuff
like that.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So
you should do both.
MARK MANDEL: You should do both.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Then, we also have a blog post,
it's called "Know They Enemy,
How to Prioritize and
Communicate Risks."
And it's part of the
series CRE Life Lessons.
CRE, as you might all know, CRE
stands for Customer Reliability
Engineering.
And we had an
episode on this back
with Luke Stone in episode 72.
So if you want to know a
little bit more about that,
definitely check it out.
But also, this blog post is
actually very interesting one.
I think you've read it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no, I
really love this blog post.
We've been talking
directly with Luke Stone.
Several episodes we've done with
Paul Newson talking about SRE,
as well, Sight
Reliability Engineering,
those two are
very, very related.
The blog post is all about how
they do a Application Liability
Review.
Basically, when they
sit down with people
they're going to support, and
say, OK, where are your risks?
Where can things go wrong?
And then, also, what
sort of SLOs and SLAs
do you want to have in
place for these things?
And so, once we've
identified the risk,
they can provide
recommendations on how
to eliminate and mitigate that
based on their experiences.
And it goes through
step by step.
It does things
like risk matrices,
and then expected losses,
it's actually really cool.
So if you're interested
in starting to do SRE
or you're already
doing SRE type things
in the company you work
for, I would definitely
give this a read.
It might give you some new
ideas and new approaches
on how you can
manage these risks
and how they relate to us SLOs
and SLAs within your company.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: That
sounds really interesting,
especially knowing
that CRE, they
work with very big customers,
so having the kind of guidance
of this is the kind of
things you should be doing--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: --to be
considered to work with CRE.
That's perfect.
Very, very useful information.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: And then
we have one last one.
He's actually a
personal blog post--
not a personal blog post, but
a personal blog post series--
MARK MANDEL: Yep
FRANSESC CAMPOY: --from our
dear teammate Cheryl Chen.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
Cheryl started this series
called The Eliza Effect.
It's not specifically
all about Google Cloud,
but she talks a lot about
artificial intelligence
and machine learning where
she's had a series of blog posts
that are really, really good.
So I just kind of
want to highlight them
because they're fantastic.
I particularly like
the one where she talks
about explaining AI to kids--
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's the one
I was looking at right now.
MARK MANDEL: --which
is super, super cool.
She's actually
traveled the world
teaching artificial
intelligence and programming
to a wide variety of students
all around the world.
And so it's just
super cool, and she
weaves pop culture
references through it
to explain it to children.
It's really, really
impressive, actually.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Not
only pop references,
but also she makes a reference
to The Imitation Game, which
is the movie about Alan Turing,
which is a film that I really
love, partly because it
stars Benedict Cumberbatch,
and I just like his name.
MARK MANDEL: Fair enough.
Awesome.
Well, I think that's
probably, I mean,
there are so many
cool things, but I
think that's enough for today.
Why don't we go chat to our
friend Steven and Christopher
and talk all about Spinnaker?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: Today, I am
delighted to have Christopher
Sansone, product manager,
and Steven Kim, software
engineering manager, both of
which on the Spinnaker product
joining us today.
How are you both doing, Chris?
CHRIS SANSONE:
Doing great, thanks.
And you, Steven,
you're doing well?
STEVEN KIM: Yeah, it's been
a wonderful week so far.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, thank you so much for
joining us today and coming
to talk to us about Spinnaker.
Love to learn more
about it, but before we
do that, why don't we talk a
little bit about who you are
and what you do.
Christopher, do you
want to go first?
CHRIS SANSONE: Great, sure.
So I'm the product manager for
Spinnaker and the larger cloud
CI/CD experience.
STEVEN KIM: And I am
the engineering manager
for the Google Spinnaker
team in the developer tooling
section of Google.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So, if
I'm not completely mistaken
and my memory is
not failing, you
were also here for container
builder episode last week.
Isn't that right, Christopher?
CHRIS SANSONE: Yes,
that is correct.
I'm a product manager for
container builder in Spinnaker,
sort of the complimentary
piece of our overall cloud
CI/CD experience.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Cool, so why don't we
get started with
Spinnaker and you
tell us a little bit,
from a very high level
point of view,
what is it, and why
people might want to use it.
CHRIS SANSONE: Sure.
So Spinnaker is a open source,
multi-cloud, continuous
delivery tool, and it's used
by companies, enterprises,
for release management, for
deploying container images,
artifacts, Deb packages, into
production cloud environments.
And it's used, basically,
for development teams
to deploy applications
quickly, reliably, and safely.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: From a
historical point of view,
when did Spinnaker happen?
We just launched-- well, we--
you, just launched the
1.0 version of Spinnaker.
But tell us a little
bit of what are
the origins of this project?
STEVEN KIM: Yeah,
yeah, Spinnaker, we're
announcing 1.0 just
now, that really
follows in the wake
of a tremendous amount
of concerted effort
that multiple teams
have put together to
arrive at where we are.
So Spinnaker, as a project,
started inside Netflix
about three years ago.
And it's the way
that they wanted
to do their
deployments internally.
And then, about 2 1/2 years
ago or so, Google joined in.
And this is prior to Spinnaker
being known externally at all.
It's been sort of a private
project inside Netflix.
And then, in November of 2015,
we announced open sourcing
to the public.
There was a lot of good
coverage around that,
and since then we've had
a number of organizations
come on and adopt it for
their own deployment purposes.
But we knew that there
were a lot of things
that needed to be done
still to really make
it ready for mass adoption and
people who didn't want to have
to tinker with it
too much for it
to be successful in their
respective organizations.
So that's what
we've been working
toward for the last
year and a half or so.
And that's what the 1.0
is a culmination of.
MARK MANDEL: So that's
really interesting.
I'm curious though, what were
the problems that Spinnaker
was built to solve that weren't
currently covered by existing
solutions in this space?
Like, were there particular
things that were a problem?
Or is there a particular
aim for this project?
STEVEN KIM: Yeah, I mean,
Spinnaker, inside Netflix,
for those of you who are
familiar with the project named
Asgard, which is also developed
internally at Netflix,
Spinnaker is sort of a
spiritual successor to Asgard.
And what Netflix
recognized, internally,
is that they are sort of the
poster child for early adoption
of public cloud with the AWS.
And back then, it was
really bare infrastructure
as a service, and there was
very little tootling out there,
so thematically, what Netflix
did, very successfully,
is build a set of
canonical tools internally.
And what they effectively did
is it raised the infrastructure
as a service to a internal
platform as a service of sorts,
right?
And so the problems that
they were trying to solve
is to create a canonical
way across Netflix
by which deployments are made
out to their public cloud.
And what that means is
taking a specific set
of opinionated approaches,
best practices,
lessons learned, about how
deployments should be done.
And that's something
that we can talk about
throughout this conversation.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Does that mean
that Spinnaker is specifically
done for [INAUDIBLE]
service architecture,
or can I use it if I'm just
deploying to virtual machines?
STEVEN KIM: Yeah,
Spinnaker certainly
has things that it is first
and foremost built on top of,
but throughout the
usage across time,
we have taken on
additional use cases.
And so today, Spinnaker supports
both VM based deployments
as well as container based
deployments, and then
actually also things like App
Engine and Open Stack, as well.
And although you could say
that it was built on a Micro
services premise,
it certainly goes
and works with a number
of different ways
that you can go ahead and
choose to use Spinnaker.
So Spinnaker has, certainly,
a set of opinions.
And it's very
prescriptive about how
to do certain things, like
immutable infrastructure,
and blue-green
deployments, and so forth.
But that doesn't stop
you from using it
how you want to go ahead
and use it and decide
for yourself what is the right
increment across time to do so.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So this is a tool
that Netflix created
to help themselves
making their deployments
more automated while
running on AWS.
Why is Google involved?
STEVEN KIM: That's
a good question.
Google recognized that
for our GCP users,
we wanted to go ahead and
provide a robust tool set that
follows in lines with
a lot of opinions
that Google actually
has internally
on how we do deployments.
So that's something
that I think it's
fair to say we have
a lot of practice at.
A lot of mistakes were
made, a lot of lessons
learned, and we have
a set of opinions
that we follow on how software
deployments should be made.
That's how Netflix does
4,000 deployments a day,
that's how Google does
25,000 releases a day,
you don't just do
that by accident.
It's through a lot
of lessons learned.
So we were looking for
a way to go ahead and do
this externally, and when we
ran into the Spinnaker project
that Netflix was doing,
we found a kindred spirit.
You know, on similar
types of problems,
similar types of scale,
and similar priorities.
So we jumped in.
And at that time, Netflix
was deploying almost entirely
to VMs, so AWSEC2s,
so we started
without adding GCE VM
support with the intention
that on an ongoing
basis, we would
continue to pour in our best
practices for our GCP users.
And a simple example of that
is we very quickly followed up
with support for
Kubernetes, and App Engine,
and then a whole
bunch of other things
that were founded based
on things at Google.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice, so you
mentioned, too, there, you
said Kubernetes, I'm assuming
Container Engine, App Engine.
Are there any other
internal projects
that this supports deployment to
or are those just the only two?
STEVEN KIM: Yeah, the full list
is AWSEC2, GCVMs, App Engine,
Kubernetes, or
GKE, and that could
be Kuberntes running on EC2s,
or GCVMs, or bare metal.
Also supports Microsoft
Azure, OpenStack,
and there's a couple of others
that are in flight right now
such as DCOS.
Mesosphere DCOS is in flight.
Oracle Cloud bare
metal is also in flight
right now, that's
pretty much complete.
That should be coming
out pretty soon.
And I'm sure we'll have many
more to go ahead and announce
as time goes forward.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool, so that
means basically anyone could
be using Spinnaker, because
no matter what you're running,
Spinnaker will run for you.
And it's also open-source.
I'm going to say that,
I'm assuming, at least.
STEVEN KIM: Yeah,
it's open source,
which also means two things
that are important to us.
One of them is that it's free.
And number two is that
we welcome full requests.
And so we're very
much also focused
on building the right
community at scale
and then sustainability.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So
I have a question
that I ask every single
time, but in what language
is this written?
STEVEN KIM: Hey, Christopher
what language is it written in?
CHRIS SANSONE: Swahili.
MARK MANDEL: And that
is the best answer
anyone has ever given.
STEVEN KIM: Spinnaker is
written in Java, Groovy,
and actually a lot of Kotlin is
beginning to make its way in,
and then of course the front
end, the web components,
are written by the standard
JS, and CSS, and HTML.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Actually, my
question, where it was going
was anyone can use Spinnaker
because it's open source
and it's available to deploy
on basically any platform,
but who should be using it?
CHRIS SANSONE: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So I think if you look at
why Spinnaker created it
and why we've seen companies
like Waze and Target adopt it,
you know, the
solutions out there
in the continuous
delivery space are not
as robust as on the
CI side of things.
So what we're seeing people
do is stitch together
a bunch of Jenkins
scripts to recreate,
essentially, the
functionality that comes out
of the box with Spinnaker, like
doing a blue-green deployment
or a rollback.
And it's pretty
complicated to do that.
You could do it with Jenkins,
you could do anything
with Jenkins, but it
wasn't really designed
for that purpose.
And so people are having
to build their own tools
or are coming from a
configuration management
background, where they're using
things like Chef and Puppet
to update running
machines versus using
an immutable infrastructure
to deploy an updated
fleet of servers.
So enterprises that
care about uptime,
care about higher
velocity releases,
would benefit a
lot from Spinnaker
without having to recreate
the wheel themselves.
Because these are
fundamental requirements
for their business, but not
knowing about Spinnaker,
a lot of people have
gone to a lot of effort
to do what Spinnaker
does for you.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So
you mentioned something
that I think is
quite interesting.
You said this phrase,
blue-green deployment.
Could you explain a little
bit for our audience,
what does that mean?
CHRIS SANSONE: Sure, so
blue-green, or red-black,
as it's actually called
in the Spinnaker world,
is a department
where you essentially
deploy a new version
of your application
to another running fleet.
But you keep your old
one around and you just
simply move your traffic
over from your old service
to your new service.
But you don't spin down
the old one quite yet,
you leave it around in case
there's an issue or a bug
and need to do a
rollback, then it's simply
as easy as re-diverting
your traffic back
to the original versus having to
sort of spin it up or redeploy
from scratch.
STEVEN KIM: And also, it's
worth mentioning, blue-green or
red-black strategy is one
that we can get in point to,
but obviously, it's not
a one size fits all.
So some organizations might
say blue-green deployments
inherently required to
x number of resources
to go ahead and do a deployment,
that is not tenable for them.
So we hear that loud and clear.
We're working on other things
like what we call a rolling
red-black, for example, which
makes better use of resource
overhead.
So if you're interested
in hearing more
about what that is, you should
definitely check that out
on the website to
get more details.
MARK MANDEL: Christopher,
you said something almost
in passing there, too,
and you said basically
that Spinnaker seems to be
a tool just for enterprise,
or you just used the word
enterprise in a sentence.
I'm wondering, right, if
I'm part of a small team--
or when should I get started
with Spinnaker is probably
the best question.
CHRIS SANSONE: Yeah,
that's a good question.
So I think if you are
experiencing any pain
around releasing
your application,
it might be worth looking at.
I think that since
Spinnaker is open source,
you do have to stand
up your own instance,
it's not a hosted SaaS service.
We, as part of this
1.0 launch, we're
launching a new tool
called Halliard,
which is a CLI command line tool
for installing and configuring
Spinnaker.
So, for people that have
tried Spinnaker in the past,
Halliard greatly
lowers the barrier
for getting it up
and running yourself.
So I think if you are a
development team that kind of
does your own DevOps
using cloud services
and are comfortable in
that world, that you
could benefit from Spinnaker.
You know, I think
what a lot of people
start with is this post
build script deployment.
You know, as part of their
CI system, they'll do a fire
and forget deploy, post bill.
They'll [INAUDIBLE]
apply, or G Cloud
app deploy, something like that.
If that works for you, great.
But I think at some
point, most companies
are looking for a more
sophisticated, more stable
deployment strategy.
STEVEN KIM: There's
an inherent aspect
of the question
you're asking which
is, when does it become worth
the overhead of operating
Spinnaker?
Right?
For your organization to think
about reaping the benefits
that Spinnaker brings.
And really, to the limit, we
hope that operationalizing--
if that's a word--
Spinnaker approaches a zero.
Another interesting analogy
to make is, for those of you
who are familiar
with App Engine,
startup teams and
small development teams
loved App Engine
because it was very
easy to go ahead and deploy
code, and all they needed to do
was concern themselves
with developer concerns,
which is writing features, and
then App Engine, as a platform,
would go ahead and
deploy that for you.
And if you look at App
Engine, it's a runtime,
but it's also a set
of front end services
that allow you to go and
deploy code, and manage
load balancers, and
traffic, and so forth.
That's what was really
neat about App Engine.
So if you imagine, as an analog,
Kubernetes is a platform.
It's an excellent, and
wonderful runtime platform.
And then, right now,
we are doing a lot
as a community, the
Kubernetes community,
trying to go ahead and make
the tooling in front of it
much easier.
So imagine if Spinnaker
were that front end tooling.
Where, to the limit
that setting up
Spinnaker becomes
a no ops operation,
then you would prefer to go
ahead and do your deployments.
And Kubernetes starts to look
a lot more like App Engine,
or, for example, if you simply
go ahead and push code 2
repository, out of the
box, without writing
your own Jenkins scripts,
or whatever it might be,
that it comes out of the box
configured to take that code,
build a container,
and then go ahead
and deploy it out
to the [INAUDIBLE]
running Kubernetes cluster.
MARK MANDEL: So
you actually almost
raised a good point there.
So if I'm using App Engine or--
I mean, the deployment
tools for Kubernetes
are actually quite nice.
You can do rolling updates,
red-green's not so hard--
why then do I want to put
Spinnaker in front of it?
What part is that
in that story that
makes this very compelling?
STEVEN KIM: Yeah, I mean, App
Engine definitely provides
a lot of automic operations
to go ahead and do things
like cut over traffic,
A/B testing, and so forth.
But it's a little more difficult
in a low level for you to go
ahead and script that, right?
So you need to make G Cloud
calls to go ahead and make
those updates.
With Spinnaker,
we have pipelines
by which can then create
a repeatable and, really,
a workflow for yourself
that then grows with you,
and matures over time,
that you go ahead
and get feedback from,
and so forth, right?
It's a benefit of
automating these things.
CHRIS SANSONE: Yeah, and this
is a really important point.
So this way you
use Spinnaker, is
that you create
pipelines deploying
to different environments
that you specify.
And, as part of that
pipeline, you defined stages.
And so those stages can be
a lot of different things.
They can be a
manual approval, it
could be a container
job, a Jenkins script.
So it's not simply
the act of deploying,
but it's the verification
and validation
that you do as part
of your deployment
or even prior to
saying that, yes, this
is production ready code.
So running load tests,
things like that
that simply focus in on
just the deployment piece
doesn't get you.
STEVEN KIM: And you
know, I'll take the part
to emphasize the other
side of that coin, which
is the infrastructure
mutating operations
that Spinnaker supports
our very, very special.
And this is a significance.
So, for example, if
you start with Jenkins
today, you're
typically interacting
with your Cloud platform via
embedded G Cloud commands
inside your Jenkins jobs and
stages and so forth, right?
Well, Spinnaker comes, out of
the box, first class cognisant
of all the platform and
the respective operations.
And here's what that means.
If you want to do-- like our
tagline that we talk about
is to do safe deployments.
And what that means is this is
a supervised safe deployment so
that when something fails in
the numerous sequence of things
that you have to
do to the platform
to do things like
blue-green to deployments,
that Spinnaker comes out
of the box understanding
the sequence of things that you
need to go ahead and complete,
and how you need go ahead
and roll those things back.
And what that means is, out
of the box, a lot of the work
that you would have
to do to really see
that full realization is
done for you, out of the box.
And that's different for
GCVMs, versus the Kubernetes
API, versus the Azure
API, for example, right?
And that's what the benefit of
supporting multiple clouds out
of the box actually means.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
You started talking about steps.
It made me think of
a Container Builder.
So I'm wondering now,
what is the relationship
between Container
Builder and Spinnaker?
Are they competitors and you
have a very interesting job?
Or do they work together?
How does this work?
CHRIS SANSONE: They are there
they are best of friends.
So Container Builder
is really around
your build and test workflow.
What we see for containers or if
you're building a Deb package,
is that Container Builder,
you can set up your triggers
on source.
And so you make a
change to source,
you build and test
your release candidate,
you put it somewhere, or
even do a Docker registry,
or artifactory, or something
like that, or GCS, S3,
what have you.
And then that new
release candidate
kicks off your Spinnaker
release pipeline.
And so, you know, as
you say, build steps,
you have a certain number of
processes or transformations
that you want to make
against your source code
as you build your artifact.
So running unit tests,
integration tests,
things like that.
And then there's a
different set of stages
that you want your now release
candidate to pass through
as you deploy it.
And so they're really two
sides of the same coin.
And it's kind of
the CI and CD sides.
It gets a little
more complicated
than that in the sense that you
can trigger Spinnaker pipelines
from Git events,
and you can actually
do a CLI based
deployment from Container
Builder as a build step.
I will leave that to
power users to find out,
but the simple
story is one of time
to get a Container Builder
plus a registry to Spinnaker.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So, just so it's
100% clear, a user
would sit down and be
like, all right, so I'm
going to do the
continuous integration,
I'm going to use a product
like Container Builder,
or maybe Jenkins, or
Travis, or whatever,
to do my integration,
my tests, make my
build artifacts
for when I'm done.
And then I'm going to take
Spinnaker to actually take
those artifacts and deploy
them to the cloud in a very
safe manner.
Is that pretty accurate?
CHRIS SANSONE: Yeah, that's
a very typical workflow.
Spinnaker has first
class integrations
with Travis CI, and Jenkins,
so you can kick off pipelines
from those CI systems directly.
And yeah, if that's
your entry point,
you know you have this
thing being built already,
and now I want to deploy it.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we're kind of
running out of time,
but I wanted to ask
one last question.
I'm convinced.
I want to use Spinnaker.
What's the next step?
What do I do?
CHRIS SANSONE: Sure,
yeah, absolutely.
So, spinnaker.io is
the web site and we
encourage people to go there.
The easiest way to get started
is there is a cloud launcher
instance, so you can use Google
Cloud Launcher to spin up
a Spinnaker instance on a VM.
You'll also see,
at spinnaker.io,
for people that are looking
to do more production grade
deployments, you can use
the CLI tool I mentioned,
Halliard, which, inside
of your Google project,
does some nice things.
Like, if you're deploying
to Kubernetes or or GKE
and standing up your Spinnaker
instance on Kubernetes,
you could follow
a walkthrough we
have for getting it set up
in about 15, 20 minutes.
STEVEN KIM: We
also have a Getting
Started code labs,
and then short videos
that you can go ahead and watch.
They're, like, five
minutes to help
you understand what we
see as a golden path
flow for different
kinds of deployments
that we typically see out there.
So we'll go ahead and definitely
link those in the notes.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And, before we wrap
up, what's next?
Is there stuff on the roadmap
for Spinnaker that you
can share with the audience?
CHRIS SANSONE: Well, we
just got 1.0 out the door.
So we'll see.
MARK MANDEL: We don't ask
for much, just everything.
CHRIS SANSONE: No,
but absolutely.
There's actually a lot of really
exciting things coming out
the door soon.
So one of the big
requests we get
is for configuration
driven pipeline management.
So we're working
on something called
declarative continuous delivery,
where Spinnaker is primarily
UI driven, although there is
an API in JSON for managing it
that way, but we're simplifying
config driven pipeline
templates for
sharing between teams
and getting set up easier.
Another really interesting one
is automated canary analysis.
So we talked about rolling
red-black deployments
and traffic splitting,
and this then
integrates with monitoring
services, so Stackdriver,
Datadog, and Prometheus,
to evaluate your deployment
and then make automated
judgments based on how it's
looking around error
rates and queue latenecy
and automatically
continuing with your release
or rolling it back for
you, which is pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, we are running out
of time, unfortunately.
I think we could
talk for a while.
Is there anything else
that we haven't mentioned,
or you want to make
sure is plugged,
or is something special
going on that didn't get
mentioned during the podcast?
CHRIS SANSONE: Yeah, I think
we have a couple of events
on the west coast this month.
We have a meet up in San
Francisco on the 20th
that we encourage
people to come to.
It's a very active
community, I would say.
I don't think we gave enough
credit to the community
as we've sort of talked about
mostly the product itself.
We have very active
Slack channel.
STEVEN KIM: It's
join.spinnaker.io.
CHRIS SANSONE: There you go.
But for a lot of
new users, and once
you go through the walkthroughs,
if you have questions,
the community is
very active on Slack,
including the Google
engineering team here.
And we would love to
see people on there.
And don't be afraid to hop
on and ask us questions.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, thank you so much to
both of you for taking the time
today to tell us a little
bit about Spinnaker and all
the cool things that
you can do with it.
CHRIS SANSONE: Great,
thank you, guys.
STEVEN KIM: All right,
thanks very much.
CHRIS SANSONE: And
I'll be here next week.
Thanks.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So thanks
again to Steven and Christopher
for such an interesting
conversation.
I definitely learned
a lot about Spinnaker.
Partly because there was
a lot that I did not know.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: But very
interesting conversation.
And then going to see
where we can use it.
We said Container
Builder is something
we are going to be using
for sure with the podcast.
Maybe Spinnaker's the next step.
Who knows?
MARK MANDEL: Who knows?
Cool so we've got our
question of the week.
We mentioned this last week
about cloud source repositories
going general availability.
But the documentation
is a little confusing.
We won't shy away from that.
So basically it says,
cloud source repositories
is free for up to five project
users per billing account.
And then, when you actually
dig into the pricing
on that, as well, it says, once
you go over five project users,
it's $1 per project user over
5 project users per month.
I was like, what
is a project user?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it is
pretty confusing, especially
because what does
it mean to access?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Does it'
mean that I have access
or that I do access it, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So what we
did, we simply go and ask.
So we asked our dear
friend Chris Sells,
he's a product manager here
at Google Cloud Platform,
and we've had them
on the podcast twice.
We had him on
episode number five,
a long time ago, on
developer experience.
And then again, we had him
for episode 49 with Windows
and .NET.
So we asked him, and his
answer was basically saying,
the important thing
to know is it is not
about the potential of
accessing a project account,
it's actually
accessing the project.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so if I'm
working on something and I
go and I pull something out of
GitHub, that's me accessing it.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Well, not GitHub.
MARK MANDEL: Not GitHub,
out of the Git repository
on the outsource repository.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and
this is reset per month.
Which means that, for
instance, let's say that--
there's two ways I
can see it, right?
I'm the only person, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: And I'm working
on four different projects
this month.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: And
then, next month, I'm
working for completely
different projects.
That is four projects a
month and four projects
together, so everything is free.
It doesn't count as
eight because I accessed
eight projects in total.
In the same way, if you have,
let's say, one single project,
but you have four people, right?
And you have four people one
month, and then the month
after that is four
completely different people.
MARK MANDEL: That's
still four people.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: That's
And four people is not eight
people or at any point,
therefore, you do
not pay for anything.
You're still free.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Let's talk a bit about
like a project user,
as well, just very
quickly, so that that's
understood, as well.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So
that's the combination
of the unique combination
of a project and a user.
So if I, personally, one
person use one project,
that's one project user.
If I go off and
use two projects,
that's two project users.
If Francesc and I
both use two projects,
that's for project users.
Because it's the unique
combination of those two
things.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Indeed, it is.
We actually count, did you
actually access it or not?
It's not about like,
the potential access
through IAM or
whatever, no, it's did
you actually access it or not?
MARK MANDEL: I believe this
stuff is going to get updated,
so it will become
clearer, but for now.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: We
complained a little bit.
We told our dear
product managers
that the communication
in the announcements
was not as clear as it should.
So hopefully, by the time you
are listening to these episode,
it had been fixed already.
MARK MANDEL: All
right, Francesc,
I believe at the moment,
you're in Beunos Aires?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: No--
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
I got that wrong.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
--I just came back.
That was last week.
I am now back and
yesterday was my birthday.
Yay!
MARK MANDEL: Happy birthday.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Everyone
send pictures
of puppies to Fransesc.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yes, please.
I love puppies.
And actually, my
next trip, I'm going
to be in New York for QCon.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I'm
going to be running a workshop
on go tooling in action.
I made a video a long time ago.
We should add a link to this
video in the show notes.
It was pretty successful
because it teaches you
how to use
performance profiling,
and debugging, and
stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: And I'm
making that a workshop,
and I'll be running
a QCon, and I'll
be also try to probably go see
if I can organize something
with the GDT, or to go
meet up with something.
If you are in New
York and you like
to organize some event related
to getting on Google Cloud,
let me know.
Send me an email.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Well,
you still on holidays?
MARK MANDEL: I am still
on holidays right now.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Oh my god.
MARK MANDEL: I know.
It's great.
So good.
But excited to be
back when I get back,
got some secret
project working on.
I have a few more
blog posts that I'm
working on in my series about
Kubernetes and game servers,
as well.
So keep an eye out
for that, as well.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
And I'm thinking that, by the
time this episode comes out,
I should have been able to
release the next [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: I hope so.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: But
that is in the future,
so I'm really hoping here.
I mean, it'd be like
seven days late.
So probably, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Probably, yes.
Awesome.
Well, Fransesc,
thank you once again
for joining me on the
podcast for another episode.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]